[Music]
foreign
with its responsibility towards these
wars has something to add to that
conversation we cannot tell a hero's
journey we cannot have a mission that
you have to do
and then in the end you're successful a
German soldier cannot come successful
out of a movie
that the balance especially when you're
writing of knowing or hoping that you're
gonna get incredible actors to be in
each of these parts there is a part of
your brain that is thinking I want to
justify each one of these people because
tonight In This Very Room a murderer
will be committed my murder
the important thing about this film is
that although it is a it is about
somebody who gets a very gloomy
diagnosis it's actually a film about not
about diet it is about living the
results have come back I'm afraid this
time
they're pretty conclusive
it's never easy this quite
during the writing of the film also
during the shooting and in the editing
of the film we were we found ourselves
time and again leaning towards
recreating moments of the film and we
found time and again that the more we
let go of the original movie
went in our own Direction the film
became much more true the end is
inevitable Maverick
the kind is headed for extinction maybe
so sorry
but not today
when I see the film I'm able to kind of
see all of our all of these little
tendrils of different people's thoughts
and dreams in the film and so you're
sort of able to be proud of it in a
different way than if it was just your
voice and that's been thrilling we know
that we are bruised and infected and
Pregnant and terrified and insane and
some of us are dead
more than anything I just wanted to be
part of
a really good story
[Music]
foreign